[Music]
this isn't any ordinary gamer I had the
reputation at the time of this mad
genius he created a bunch of companies
focusing on robots automobile navigation
microwave components and a bunch of
others he is the man who launched the
video game revolution but there's one
more creation you may not know about a
place where a kid can be a kid
let's welcome creative genius Nolan
Bushnell Nolan Bushnell in many ways you
can trace the history of video games all
the way back to this man Nolan Bushnell
in 1972 Nolan co-founded one of the
first video game companies they called
it Atari their first hit is a table
tennis game called pong it sets record
sales and permanently changed the arcade
world even though arcades were hitting
critical mass families were still
hesitant to accept them into their lives
to change hearts and minds Nolan knew
that our Cades needed a new and friendly
face this is the story of how he
introduced the world to a new mascot of
gaming chucky cheese
[Music]
in the 1970s and 80s this is what a
video game looked like yeah it doesn't
look like much but back then games like
these turned Atari into a multi-billion
dollar company
[Music]
at Atari we had explosive growth we were
just printing money because we were lean
and mean and had good games but having
good games wasn't enough the market was
saturated and Atari needed to break into
a new demographic
I wanted to create a chain of big
arcades focusing on kids that even
passed laws restricting the use of the
games but there were certain cities that
didn't want to have our caves because
teenagers came and they'd cause trouble
so I felt that disguising at his
restaurant was a good business strategy
chucky cheese was an arcade masquerading
as a restaurant though nolan had the
idea he needed someone to turn it into a
reality so he tapped one of the
brightest business minds with an atari a
man as ambitious as he was a man as
crazy as he was me the first president
of chucky cheese gene Landrum
I have been pretty competitive my life I
was twenty years old I was mr. Fort
Lauderdale I went a hundred tennis
tournaments so I did business kind of
the same way I happen to be an
aggressive guy and you'll get it done
and win the game when Nolan hired me to
do this I actually looked at myself and
said what do you know about food Jean
not thing but that was a risk Nolan
wanted to take he knew that creating
something unorthodox required
visionaries not experts set in their
ways experts don't understand the future
too many times you have to untie
so when it came to spinning up the
Chucky Cheese project I thought Jane
would be the perfect guy so where did
Jean start well with food
Pizza makes sense because families left
pizza and guess what it takes 20 minutes
to make a pizza so while they're waiting
the kids are playing the games and I had
Chuck actually deliver the pizza now I
went down south and find the guy who did
costumes for Disney I said look I don't
want a mouse Disney's got Mickey and I
don't want a rat is too hardcore I want
a soft rat and he did it and after only
three months of work chucky cheese pizza
time theatre opened its doors for the
first time on May 17th 1977
[Music]
everybody is willing to say that talking
robots in a pizza parlor with a lot of
games was a really stupid idea and in
fact the day we opened I knew we'd
screwed up the place wasn't big enough
[Music]
my joint was filled there wasn't a seat
and once I learned how to do it I opened
a store a week 50 stores I opened in one
year
I have no fear I knew that it was going
to do well
Chucky cheese's initial stores were a
hit but at the parent company Atari
things were going a little differently
Warner bought Atari and all of a sudden
you had a whole bunch of New York suits
pruning my pet projects I was really
upset about that and it dawned on me
that I was having a lot more fun working
on Chucky Cheese than on Atari and so
Nolan eventually left Atari overtime the
company struggled and faded away as the
spotlight turned to new gaming giants
like Nintendo
but while kids today may not know the
name Atari chuck-e-cheese is still a
childhood hotspot after 40 years the
buck-toothed Pizza serving stuffed rat
still stands as a testament to Nolan's
innovation in the video game industry it
was a whirlwind was more successful than
I thought it would ever be
but chucky cheese it's a viable concept
it makes sense it still makes sense
there's a vanishingly small number of
places where parents and children can
have a fun night out and that was one of
the goals you know I feel good about
that I saw it I did it I was at the
beginning enough
[Music]